[Music]
[Applause]
well hello dear friends uh once again we
want to thank you for supporting this
program I'd like to know uh we
appreciate your prayers and we also
appreciate your financial support so
that we can continue uh producing
programs such as this as well as our
worship service and also series of
presentations on different Bible
doctrines and prophecies uh we want to
thank you for joining us today on our
program uh many of you probably know
that this is a question and answer
program where you send us your questions
we do the research and then we do the
best that we can to answer the questions
based on our research I want to give you
the address where you can send us your
questions it'll be on the screen
TVM tv.org once again TVM tv.org we are
delighted uh to be able to uh be with
you on this program and we trust that
you will send us your questions and that
you will tune in on the program that we
do once a week I have with me a good
friend and fellow worker here at Secrets
unsealed in sutv someone who loves the
ministry amen uh who loves to study the
word of God has a wonderful family and
is very supportive of the mission of
Secrets unsealed in Su TV thank you
Pastor Salasar for participating in this
program I'd like to know thank you
Pastor it's really one of our favorite
programs everywhere we go uh people are
always telling us you know how much they
love the program and we do make
sometimes mistakes and we're not
infallible you know but we want to
search in the scriptures the truth and
that's our you know our promise to the
viewers and of course to the Lord that
we want to share what the Lord has said
and not our own ideas or thoughts you
know so people need to check us out yes
that's you know just because we answer
your question doesn't mean that you
should take it at face value exactly uh
you have to do what the bans did with
Paul you know you have to check out the
verses that we read and the concepts
that we share the quotations from the
spirit of Prophecy to make sure that
they're used in context and that the
answers are biblically and spirit of
Prophecy correct amen so uh we are far
from claiming uh
infallibility uh you know we are uh weak
human beings just uh attempting to be in
harmony with what God teaches in his
holy word now uh we have a very
interesting question as we begin today
but before we get into the questions we
want to have a word of prayer always
before we begin to answer questions so
would you please pray for us absolutely
Pastor bour let's pray Heavenly Father
we are come before you and we thank you
once again for allowing us to spend time
uh first with you in prayer and also to
spend time in your word we know that you
have all the wisdom all the knowledge
all the understanding and everything uh
to you is no mystery but for us finite
man finite finite human beings it's hard
sometimes to know or to see the truth
but we pray now that you will give us
the unction of the holy spirit so that
as we speak and we open your word may
you really uh come through us and bring
those that are watching and listening to
a closer relationship with you a closer
understanding of your word we pray for
all of these in Precious name of Jesus
amen
amen okay I'm going to read the question
and then I'll pass it on to you all
right this question uh is actually not a
unique question I've heard it before uh
but uh I think that we need to answer it
it comes from Kelvin in mosm Beek praise
the Lord people in mosm Beek are are
watching our program uh this is a
question good evening Pastor bore and I
would include Pastor Salasar my question
is this I want to know if it is a sin
for a person to wear clothes belonging
to the opposite sex that is for a woman
to wear men's pants and a man to wear a
skirt according to Deuteronomy 22:5 so
why don't we read Deuteronomy 22:5 first
of all and then we'll try to unpack it
absolutely let's read this verse there
in Deuteronomy
22:5 it says there the woman shall not
wear that which pertaineth unto a man
neither shall a man put on a woman's
garment for all that do so are
Abomination unto the Lord thy God so
here we have a verse Pastor that is very
direct and very clear you know it says
there that those that a woman or a man
should not put on uh the Garment of a
woman neither vice versa neither the
woman put on the Garment of a man and I
think that uh you know just to kind of
make this a little you know clear or I
suppose important back then when the
Jewish the Israelites
where uh in that experience they usually
use robes you know there was not such a
thing as pants for men or skirts for
women so I have to you have to be you
know we have to keep that in mind they
use both genders use similar I guess
types of robes but they were made
specifically or for for one type and the
men would have a specific type for them
they were similar in characteristics so
but they're not essentially the same
piece of clothing another thing that
this very sort of implying is that the
the Abomination comes from a person
let's say I'm a male and I put on wom's
garments to portray myself as a woman
that's mainly the introdu this is really
what the the verse is really emphasizing
the the idea of putting on the attire of
a woman so that I appear as a woman or
vice versa for a woman to put on a
male's garment so that she no longer
looks like a woman I think this is the
this is really based on the on the
context of the vers and based of the
conditions this is really the mo main
emphasis of this verse you know
sometimes people say oh pants today are
for men only and skirts for women that
is not necessarily what this verse is
saying and I have to you know that I
wanted to clear that up because
sometimes there is this idea that pants
are only for men and this is really not
the case because there were not even
pants there so yeah you know there are
some women's pants that are quite uh
modest right of course and you can
really tell the difference between a man
and a woman it's not only the pants
right but also the other attire that the
person uses the length of the hair and
the the what the face looks like and so
on there are many characteristics that
distinguish a man from a woman um I
think that the main principle of this
whole thing uh is found in the Book of
Genesis at the very beginning y uh you
know it says that God made two genders
yes to be distinct male and female it
say says in in Genesis 1:26 then God
said let us make man in our image
according to our likeness let them have
dominion over the fish of the sea over
the birds of the air over the cattle
over uh everything that creeps on the
earth go so God created Man In His Image
in the image of God he created him male
and female he created them in fact at
creation God made lots of distinctions
between Heaven and Earth between the dry
and the and the sea between good and
evil uh it seems like God wanted to
establish that there's a there needs to
be a clear distinction between male and
female uh and this of course would uh
have something to say about the emphasis
these days on transgender you know an
individual changing their gender
supposedly although they're really not
changing their gender no matter how much
they say they are um I think that that
the principle is that God wants us to to
seek clearly the gender distinction
between male and female and that not
only includes their dress it includes uh
everything yes and and it's important
you know that uh we realize it is a it
is an Abomination it is a sin for for
before the Lord to try to blurry that
distinction of being a male and a female
and I believe that more important than
you know the idea of just wearing
clothes you know it's more the fact of
what
really you know blurs that that that
vision of Who You Are God made you a
male you need to wear clothes that are
for males and if you are a female the
Lord wants you to wear clothes that are
apparent and and make sure that you're a
female now we think that there of course
there's the modesty issue that have to
be considered you know for for women and
men to both be modest not to wear things
that are going to you know bring shame
to the the Lord and his name and so
these are things but you know besides
you know without going into that part of
the idea of of of of clothing we have to
realize that the main emphasis is we you
know God wants men to be males and and
females you know women to be females and
and and be certain that we in that we
teach our children that there is roles
and even our clothing is is important
and it identifies who we are so
basically what it's saying is that we
should not be trans vites absolutely in
other words a man should not use women's
clothing to make people think she's a
woman he's a woman right and vice versa
yeah uh so you know I can see a woman
that has a pair of pants that are very
modest you know with a blouse yeah over
their their midsection and I can tell
that she's a woman right uh so it's not
the issue necessarily of pants right
it's the issue of everything the hair
the look of their face uh you know uh
the the the the blouse that they use uh
all of that uh is involved I think in
this specific verse I I agree pastor and
just one last thing to I like to add to
this concept in a lot of cultures the
there are a lot of traditions where
males will wear or dress up as women you
know for entertainment for whatever uh
these are Customs that were Pagan and
the Lord wanted to avoid them from
fulfilling and to follow that type of
custom even today uh in many countries
there are you know people use Customs to
look who they are not again these are
principles that are contrary to the Lord
of you know the word of God and who we
he made us and the enemy is the one that
yes uses dis SK you know Customs to to
to portray who he is not so uh I think
that we have to be very careful and
that's what the Lord says that is a
Abomination is a sin for women to appear
to be a man and vice versa for a man to
appear to be a woman okay good I hope
this is helpful in our answer uh let's
go to our next question this comes from
Andre in Romania praise the Lord the
Lord have people that are watching our
program in Romania uh it's uh has
several questions actually uh maybe we
can just take them one by one he also
makes a he makes a comment uh first of
all uh so why don't you read the comment
that he makes about I'd like to know and
then uh go we'll go through the
questions one by one absolutely he says
the following first first of all I would
like to thank you for the great work you
do I discovered your YouTube channel
last year and went through several Bible
studies you posted these Studies have
helped me greatly in solidifying my
decision to be baptized as a sday
Adventist amen praise the Lord for that
yes sometime ago I also discovered I
like to know series which I find very
helpful especially for people who have
only recently discovered 7-Day adventism
like me and face many challenges I
didn't get to see many episodes of I
like to know Series so I apologize is
some of the questions have already been
answered so what aing you know that the
Lord is using the work the ministry to
be able to reach those that are learning
from the amen praise the Lord we're very
thankful to hear positive comments like
this uh they they are music to our ears
they warm our hearts because uh we know
that the ministry is making a difference
and you know as I
travel the most common comment that I
get is I love I'd like to know yes you
know they don't say you know we like the
series on Daniel or Revelation once in a
while you have people that will say we
came into the church through seeing
those programs but uh invariably people
say we'd love that question answer
program I'd like to know and you've had
the same experience absolutely Pastor
the Lord has shown us that God is using
our ministry in a way to reach people
that are having questions and they're
you know Seekers of truth and that's
what really encourages us you know know
okay so let's go to question number one
yes the first question he sends us is
the following regarding the historicist
interpretation of the seven churches in
Revelation I received the following
question how do you explain the verse of
Revelation 2:16 which addresses the
Church of pergamus repent or else I will
come unto thee quickly and will fight
against them with the sword of my mouth
in the context that the Church of
pergamus represents a period of church
history that ended with the loss of the
Candlestick the loss of the Candlestick
implies lack of repentance then
shouldn't it automatically imply the
return of the Lord's Jesus so he has
this question I think he was uh maybe he
has a question or they came to him with
that question if we understand
Revelation 7 or the seven Church of
Revelation the historical part of
Revelation this church of pergamus
Pastor is it possible that that removing
the candlestick meant going to Darkness
or the return of Christ I think that's
the main question yeah the the bottom
line is that the seven churches
represent seven periods of church
history however there's more to the
story yes than that and that is that
they also
describe individual characteristics of
persons throughout the course of
Christian history in other words there
might be persons in the Church of oia
that have characteristics of pergamus
yes there might be people uh in the
Church of Philadelphia that have
characteristics of fyra yeah so in other
words uh there is a um sequential
interpretation to the seven churches and
there is also an individual application
uh to the seven churches so when Jesus
says I will come with the sword of my
mouth uh he's talk Talking also to
individuals who might live not during
the period of pergamus right but they're
living at the end of time but their
spiritual experience is the spiritual
experients of pergamus right and so
those are the ones that are being
addressed but the description given of
each church is speaking about the
central tenor of the Church of most
people during that period right uh it's
not speaking about individuals who might
have characteristics of other churches I
don't know if that uh helps well
absolutely and I think that is important
you mentioned that you know there is the
line linear understanding and the Church
of pergamus which is I believe the
fourth
Church uh or the third church or the
fourth church I think I have to make
sure um well this church is again a
period of time that preceded the
churches that followed this is this the
history of God's Church throughout the
ages and so because of that you know the
lack of the Candlestick if the Lord
remov moves that candles stick is not
necessarily the end of the world is not
necessarily meaning that that's when
Christ comes we have to understand that
uh that to that church if they did not
repent if they did not come to the Lord
he will remove the light of that church
which uh it was a period of time of you
know the great darkness of time in the
time of of of the 1260 years of Pap you
know Dy so we have that experience and
this is why I think that uh it's it's a
warning to those that were living in
that time frame that unless they
repented unless they came to the Lord
the truth they will not have any more
light in them uh but it's not
necessarily the end of the world as we
know that there are churches five six
and seven that were were to come later
and so this is why uh you know we have
to keep that in mind that the the
historical aspect points us to time
frames of Earth's church history you
know and the general tenor of the church
at that time yeah um but but there might
have been uh there might have been in
thyra people who had characteristics of
pergamus Etc so anyway there's an
individual application of the seven
churches and there is also a uh time
frame interpretation where you have
segments of church history being
described in the sequence of churches
that's right and and the churches can
apply the messages can apply to us even
today a message can be applied in the
experience not in the time we're not re
interpreting the scriptures or re
reinterpreting the the the historical
aspect but the message itself has a
message for us to learn from the
experience or to apply to our experience
if we're you know living today and you
know the evidence for this is uh if you
look at Ellen White's commentaries on
the seven churches you'll find that
constantly she uses the warnings in the
churches to apply to the church today
exactly uh to individuals in the church
today so um we need to understand the
distinction between the two amen amen
okay what's the next question the next
question he comes from Andre again and
he's continuing he says how can we
reconcile Galatians 3:17 with Exodus
12:40 regarding biblical chronology and
I had a actually look at these verses
and I had a little you know question
what exactly he was trying to say
because uh looking into both verses uh
in mentions Paul for example in
Galatians 317 and we can read that very
briefly and I I'm reading let's read
both of yeah let's read both verses and
maybe you know if we need to have a you
know more of a Clarity of what he was
asking but let's read what verses Pastor
you read Galatians 3:17 and I'll read
Exodus 12:40 Galatians 3:17 says and
this I say that the law which was 430
years later cannot anull the Covenant
that was confirmed before by God in
Christ that it should make the promise
of no effect so it speaks about 430
years later right and then then in
Exodus
12:40 he says uh the King James version
at least says this now the souring of
the children of Israel who dwelt in
Egypt was
430 years so uh both verses mentioned
430 years
um this is from this experience of the
children of Israel in Egypt 400 430
years and uh in
I think Paul's mentioned the exact same
moment um so I exactly not sure what he
where his confusion is with Andre and um
but both verses at least in our version
I don't know maybe a Romanian version
has a different number but at least in
the in the K version and or new K
version they are 430 years yeah okay
very good um maybe if he wants to write
a followup yeah uh we'll look further
into it uh to see uh you know exactly
what he means all right we have three
more questions but we'll just probably
have time for one more from Andre and
says uh the third question he has is how
can we understand 1 Corinthians
10:25 in relation to the
interdiction or I assuming he's an
introduction of eating unclean animals
but in relation to health reform in
terms of avoiding eating any kind of
Flesh so how can we understand 1
Corinthians 10:25 in relation to the
introduction of eating unclean animals
but in in relation to the health reform
so uh you have that verse pastor and
let's read that verse yes uh it says eat
whatever is sold in the meat market
asking no questions for conscience
sake okay so
um when when he writes that he's not
overturning the distinction between
clean and unclean Meats in the Old
Testament right uh as a good Jew who
spoke nothing against the law of Moses
he said several times yeah when he stand
stood before Ag gria and before Festus
he says I have taught nothing but was it
what is in what was written by Moses he
would not be saying you know that uh
it's okay to go to the market and and
buy some oysters and and buy some shrimp
and to buy some uh some pork some pig
you know or camel meat or something like
that uh what he's saying is go to the
market and use what is in harmony with
the principles that God has established
in his word yes and it's actually that's
what he says later in the same chapter
he's speaking of how uh you know some
people had an issue if the meat was
offered to idols and and who were not
and he's saying for me that's not a
problem but you know if somebody's weak
in the faith you know I I I'll I'll I'll
avoid it but basically saying in the
market you may have people who are not
you know were not Jews who are not or or
do not understand the faith or the
principles but if they are selling
products or or even Meats according to
what the Lord allowed they could eat
them you know buy them from them they
could buy from these these people that
were not Jewish in per se or were not
following the customs of the Jews and so
this is for us today you know we don't
have to go to a you know a koser per se
you know place to buy items you know we
can buy from groceries even though they
break the sabath and they do a lot of
things you know they sell wine and and
drinks and alcohol and stuff like that
so we can buy what is approved by the
Lord you know even if they themselves
you know don't understand or follow the
commands of God a and the the context
indicates that the conflict here was not
what you eat yeah but eating meat that
is sold in the market that was offered
idles right he says you know if there's
going to be people offended if you eat
meat uh that you bought at the market
that they know was offered to Idols so
for the sake of the weaker brother we'll
avoid it don't don't partake of that
meat uh but it's in unconscionable that
he would be saying that any meat yeah in
the market can be eaten uh when Paul was
a a staunch Hebrew right and uh and
besides that issue of not eating unclean
Foods uh that is not ceremonial right it
has to do with your physical health
right that that is being spoken of here
so if you continue reading I would
suggest that you read verse 23 all the
way to verse 33 so you catch the entire
context that the conflict is not what
you eat that you bought at the market
but if you eat meat that was offered to
Idols at the market that's what the
context is clearly teaching of this
verse and just to you know he asked in
about avoiding eating any kind of Flesh
well that's a lie that the Lord has
given us today as a special people you
know to go back to Genesis you know that
that concept of eating what the Lord has
made for mankind which was originally
the plan of a vegetarian diet or a vegan
diet but that's not necessarily what
this verse is saying and is not implying
that we have to follow that uh right now
and in the next program we'll deal with
questions four and five amen which have
to do with why did Jesus eat meat amen
okay so don't miss the next program
thank you for joining us God bless you
hope to see you at our Next program I'd
like to know God bless
[Music]